bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis très
heureuse d'être parmi vous
je suis donc prof de français au lycée
mais pas que
au-delà en fait de la littérature que
j'enseigne avec passion et que j'essaye
de transmettre
j'essaye de transmettre également
d'autres valeurs humaines
parmi elles il y en a une qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur
c'est l'attention
on dirait pourquoi la tension parmi tant
d'autres
parce que c'est un lien avec un
événement personnel de ma vie et c'est
cet événement là qui a déterminé la
mienne d'un temps d'attention en fait
dans ma vie de femme mais dans ma vie
également de prof
j'étais en troisième j'avais un camarade
de classe qui était super super jovial
souriant un petit peu le beau gosse de
la classe toutes les filles étaient love
love moi c'était mon grand frère
et puis un jour il a commencé à me dire
plus que 7 jours c'est le jour pourquoi
pas de réponse
le lendemain plus que 6 jours qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans ces jours pas de
réponse sourire
puis on vous en doutez ça s'est grainé
comme ça de jour en jour et puis un
mardi j'étais à la cantine il se
retourne il me dit c'est demain et
demain quoi c'est demain sourire blague
on n'avait pas cours le mercredi jeudi
matin j'arrive en cours et je le vois
pas première heure de cours notre
principal vient dans la salle pour nous
annoncer qu'il s'était suicidé la veille
ça a marqué ma vie
on n'a jamais su pourquoi
on a jamais su pourquoi il était parti
mais vous en doutez que moi je me suis
posé beaucoup de questions et à partir
de là j'ai scruté les sourires les
regards j'ai fait attention et je crois
que l'innovation de l'éducation elle
peut se trouver là
dans l'attention qu'on porte à l'autre
alors quand on est prof on sait on a 36
élèves comment faire attention à chacun
d'entre eux individuellement alors moi
j'ai un petit truc c'est trois rituels
pour rentrer en classe
alors imaginez que vous êtes mes élèves
beaucoup plus nombreux et que je vous
accueille dans une salle tous un par un
et je vous accueille à ma façon et ma
façon elle est pas compliqué elle est là
c'est bonjour
sourire et se regarder dans les yeux
alors je fais ça en classe le premier
jour et j'installe ces rituels mais je
pose la question pourquoi on se dit
bonjour alors à votre avis pourquoi on
se dit bonjour
par politesse oui par politesse par
respect et moi je leur dis mais en fait
prof de français oblige décomposer le
mot bon jour on se chouette on se
souhaite une bonne journée mais vous
imaginez deux secondes qu'à la place de
bonjour je vous dis je vous souhaite une
journée pourrie les gars
c'est pas la même ambiance êtes-vous
d'accord pour qu'on se soit un bon jour
généralement oui on est d'accord
deuxième chose avez-vous remarqué
comment je vous ai accueilli encore très
vite on va me dire vous avez souri
individuellement oui je vous ai souri et
pourquoi on sourit à votre avis
alors certains me disent par politesse
par respect d'autres me diront c'est
plus agréable et oui imaginez deux
secondes que je vous accueille comme ça
tu vis ton nom
mais ça donne pas envie
et là effectivement je leur dis aussi il
m'a imaginé 2 secondes que je vous vois
arriver 36 en faisant un petit peu sa
tête ça donne pas envie donc on va
essayer de se donner envie et donc de ce
sourire
troisième chose il met un peu de temps
en fait à trouver puis au bout d'un
moment il y en a certains qui disent
mais en fait vous nous avez également
regardé dans les yeux pourquoi on se
regarde dans les yeux
vous en doutez il y a à peu près les
mêmes réponses à par respect par
politesse le romantique de la classe
vous dira parce que le regard c'est le
reflet de l'âme
effectivement
mais là je leur explique en fait quand
vous regardant dans les yeux je vous
considère
je fais attention à vous de façon
individuelle dans un groupe classe vous
êtes une personne dans un collectif et
donc je vais faire attention à vous êtes
ok pour qu'on se fasse à qu'on fasse
attention l'un à l'autre oui et les
trois rituels se mettent en place comme
ça alors il y a autre chose que j'aime
beaucoup aussi c'est leur apprendre à
parler avec attention parler avec
bienveillance et je passe cette fois par
la communication non violente à la
communication non violente c'est pas
compliqué dès le début de l'année je
leur explique que j'ai un besoin de
silence mais c'est un besoin vital parce
que je suis hyperesthésique et que je
suis sensible au moindre bruit donc le
BIC on entend en cours c'est horrible
pour moi la chaise qui grince pas
possible les bavardages encore moins je
pourrais leur dire
silence taisez-vous
je pourrais leur dire mais j'ai choisi
en fait de passer par la communication
non violente ça veut dire quoi observer
en fait ce qu'il se passe ça veut dire
également exprimer en fait son émotion
ça veut dire également donner son besoin
et puis finalement formuler la demande
qui en découle et ça donne
bon je suis très sensible au bruit
j'en vois qu'il y a des bavardages j'ai
besoin vraiment du silence pour faire un
cours je vous propose donc je vous
invite si vous le voulez bien à faire le
silence et quand ça ne va pas que je
suis fatiguée je fais la même chose ça
va pas fort aujourd'hui je vais avoir
besoin de vous pour coopérer afin de
faire un cours de façon optimale
êtes-vous OK et très sincèrement quand
vous faites votre demande avec
bienveillance que vous exprimez vos
émotions vous obtenez l'adhésion en fait
de ceux qui se trouve face à savon ça
veut dire que vous pouvez faire aussi la
même chose avec n'importe quel collectif
avec n'importe quelle personne devant
vous et quoi qu'il arrive si vous savez
faire ça de l'autre côté il se sentiront
également à l'aise pour exprimer les
leurs d'émotion
et vous serez attentif à leurs émotions
aussi
je passe aussi par la psychologie
positive à la psychogi positive c'est
vraiment pas compliqué c'est en fait
essayer de mettre en valeur les qualités
les réussites les capacités de chacun
d'entre nous et un exercice que
j'affectionne particulièrement c'est de
trouver ses propres qualités donc je des
fois ça m'arrive de leur dire ou de
façon individuelle trouve-toi des
qualités si tu arrives pas tu as droit à
l'appel à la mi donc tu appelles un ami
ou bien tu envoies un petit SMS à la
famille et tu demandes trois de tes
qualités ce soir faites-le juste pour le
kiff vous insistez sur le mot qualité
quand même pour pas avoir autre chose en
retour et donc vous allez recevoir trois
qualités qu'on peut en fait vous donner
c'est une bouffée d'oxygène ça réhausse
son estime de soi et ça donne confiance
en soi aussi et faire attention à ses
qualités c'est aussi une façon de
réussir sa vie personnelle et sa vie
professionnelle être conscient de ses
qualités
accueillir avec attention
donner ses émotions avec attention
la tension ça s'apprend aussi et ça
s'apprend par quoi mais ça s'apprend par
la méditation de pleine conscience que
certains appellent présence attentive et
la présence attentive c'est finalement
quelque chose qui peut aider en fait la
capacité de concentration pourquoi parce
qu'il y a des neurosciences aujourd'hui
qui ont montré et je pense notamment à
l'équipe d'Antoine Lutz qui ont montré
que la méditation de pleine conscience
augmentait la capacité d'attention et
les IRM ont également montré ça c'est
vraiment nouveau que cela augmentait la
matière crise dans les zones du cerveau
qui étaient impliquées dans les zones
d'apprentissage dans les zones de
concentration les zones de planification
et ça c'est hyper intéressant en fait
quand on le sait
lever la main ceux qui ont moins de 25
ans
waouh
vous êtes prêts pour l'annonce
j'ai le regard de vous dire que votre
cerveau n'est pas totalement terminé
voilà merci pour tout ce bonheur vous
rentrez avec une information primordiale
ce soir n'est ce pas alors pour
l'explication il y a une zone qui
s'appelle le cortex préfrontal qui est
en charge justement en fait des
apprentissages de la planification de la
concentration et qui mature autour de 25
ans ça veut pas dire que vous n'êtes pas
totalement fini vous savez juste dire
que vous êtes en train de maturer mais
ça veut aussi dire et quand on sait ça
c'est ça en fait vraiment qui est
important ça veut dire en fait lorsque
je vais vous dire là maintenant tout de
suite concentrez-vous
il y en a certains en fait qui me fixent
d'autres qui sont redressés
mais concrètement vous ne savez pas quoi
faire
et bien pour les élèves c'est pareil ils
ne savent pas quoi faire ils entendent
l'injonction mais concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire quand elle nous demande
de nous concentrer ils savent pas alors
concrètement ce qu'on peut faire c'est
de la méditation plein de conscience ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire 5 à 10
minutes par jour se concentrer sur un
élément interne par exemple le souffle
et on sait que le souffle est la posture
du corps c'est vraiment ce sont vraiment
des choses très importantes on sait par
exemple que pour un exercice oratoire il
faut travailler le souffle il faut
également travailler la posture du corps
l'ancrage l'équilibre preuve en est si
je me présente à vous un petit peu
courbé en regardant le sol ma voix ne va
pas être projetée la même façon et
l'impact de mon image ne sera pas tout à
fait le même alors que si je me redresse
et que je les épaules en arrière
forcément en fait l'image sera un peu
différente et vous doutez que c'est
important quand on fait travailler des
élèves sur un exercice oral
alors il y a une chose aussi très
intéressante c'est que grâce aux
neurosciences on voit en fait par des
images
où en fait fonctionnent enfin où
sont les conséquences de la méditation
pleine conscience alors c'est le même
cerveau mais pris à des phases
différentes de la méditation de pleine
conscience vous avez en fait le premier
qui s'appelle vagabondage dans de
l'esprit ou plusieurs zones sont
sollicitées alors concrètement ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que si par
exemple vous vous concentrez sur votre
souffle vous allez effectivement vous
concentrer sur votre souffle et à un
moment donné il y a peut-être une pensée
parasite qui va arriver il faut que je
mange ce soir j'ai pas fait les courses
j'ai rien dans le frigo faut que j'aille
faire les courses il faut que j'aille
faire du coup de l'essence parce que
j'en ai plus dans la voiture mais
l'essence à augmenter mince il va
falloir que je prenne le vélo le vélo et
de gonfler et à un moment donné vous
allez quand même revenir parce que vous
êtes rendu compte que vous étiez parti
un peu loin c'est votre deuxième cerveau
vous prenez conscience effectivement que
vous revenez et hop vous revenez sur
votre souffle et au fur et à mesure
d'une pratique régulière et assidue
encore une fois on parle de 5 à 10
minutes par jour Christophe André dira
que c'est un entraînement de l'esprit
donc ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas obligé
de faire une heure par jour en revanche
il vaut mieux 5 10 minutes par jour
plutôt qu'une heure par semaine voilà et
donc au fur et à mesure vous allez voir
que votre cerveau ne va solliciter
qu'une seule zone donc la focalisation
soutenue c'est votre quatrième en fait
schéma que vous avez devant les yeux et
effectivement ça va augmenter en fait
votre capacité de concentration
alors juste pour vérifier si vous avez
tout compris je vous propose de vivre un
instant de pleine présence de présence
attentive et je vais vous demander de
bien vouloir vous lever s'il vous plaît
je vais vous inviter juste à en créer
votre corps par terre donc juste détendu
peut-être les bras le long du corps pour
être vraiment détendu si vous le
souhaitez si vous vous sentez ok là
dessus vous pouvez fermer les yeux et
juste prendre une grande respiration
pour commencer vous allez commencer par
inspirer par le nez
et on en trouvant légèrement la bouche
on va expirer par la bouche l'air qu'on
engrangé
et on peut faire ça encore une fois on
inspire par le nez
et on expire légèrement doucement
lentement par la bouche
allez encore une fois
on va garder juste cette posture si
possible avec les yeux fermés on va
juste essayer de prendre conscience de
son rythme de respiration normale
sans vouloir changer quoi que ce soit on
accueille juste avec bienveillance ce
qu'il se passe là à l'intérieur de nous
comment je me sens
comment je me sens ici et maintenant
je ne juge pas
je fais juste attention
tranquillement
à ce qu'il se passe à l'intérieur de moi
je vais reprendre une grande respiration
et tranquillement je vais pouvoir
remettre mon corps en mouvement en
commençant par les pieds les jambes le
haut du corps je peux m'étirer si j'en
ressens le besoin bâiller si ça vient
j'aurais ouvrir les yeux au dernier
moment s'ils étaient fermés je pourrais
reprendre ma place
voilà
aujourd'hui j'ai voulu partager ce que
j'ai découvert de plus important dans
mon métier de prof un autre rapport à
l'autre un rapport plus attentif une
attention plus soutenue à l'autre mais
attention également qui est importante
pour moi
toutes et tous ici aujourd'hui vous avez
porté votre attention sur mon discours
moi ici maintenant je vous regarde
et je vous invite vraiment à vivre cette
expérience fabuleuse cette expérience de
d'attention
être attentif dans vos vies
dans votre vie personnelle
dans votre métier
dans vos activités
être attentif aux gens que vous
rencontrez aux gens qui sont mis sur
votre chemin
distillons de si de là des petites
bulles d'attention
parce que c'est peut-être ça aussi une
forme d'amour
je portais son attention à l'autre
c'est peut-être ça aussi qui fera qu'un
jour on pourra doucement à son propre
rythme changer et améliorer le monde de
l'éducation
merci
de votre attention